I'm gonna be using my iPad for notes I
promise I'm not
cack most of the time so I'm a huge nerd
for start-up history
I spent a fairly considerable fraction
of my leisure time of the past year
reading histories of Oracle and
Microsoft and Facebook it was really
exciting but there's this phenomenon
where if you're interested in startups
or if you're thinking start if you're
thinking of starting a company you don't
quite get the full picture because
companies want to put the best face
forward they want to whitewash things a
little bit and so you then you don't end
up seeing the really interesting detail
and the uncertainty from the early days
of a company and so what I'm gonna try
to do over the course of talk do today
is give you a little bit of insight into
that uncertainty into what it's like in
the early days and if I don't do a good
job of that in in this part we'll be
going into questions maybe half an hour
in and you can ask the the tricky
questions so maybe we should start off
with what is stripe and this is not
maybe as easy a question as as it sounds
so one answer is that stripe is a really
easy way to accept payments online this
is why we started this back in 2009 when
we had been developing web products
would we we have been developing apps
and you know the two options you really
had if you wanted to turn your product
into a business where one you could send
your users off site to PayPal that
experience kind of sucked or two you
could sign up for a merchant account and
go through the weeks of work and
building out your own payments
infrastructure that that entails neither
option was really good and so you know
one way to look at stripe is is that a
better way that came along too to accept
payments but if you zoom out a little
bit you can look at as a platform for
running your online business so we've
seen thanks to the internet an explosion
of not just new businesses but new kinds
businesses new business models you look
at software that previously was sold on
a license basis is now all delivered via
the cloud as software as a service it's
all subscription services or you see
that services that were previously kind
of offline delivered on an ad-hoc basis
are being delivered by marketplaces that
can help with discovery and liquidity
and trust and safety I'm talking about
Airbnb for travel or lyft and uber in
the in the transport segment and it goes
you know into every vertical like like
home cleaning or errands and so as all
these new business models emerge to
actually to run the business if you're a
subscription business to keep track of
how much everyone is paying you and
actually build them or if you're a
marketplace to run the pretty complex
operations and move all the money around
in in a variety of different companies
to make that happen and this was hugely
challenging for people and they were all
doing it themselves
and so what stripe really does is gives
them a platform so that they can use
stripe for all that and not have to
build it themselves so maybe that's
another definition but if you zoom out
even further maybe stripe is just better
economic infrastructure for the internet
thanks to the way the Internet is
emerged we have this global system that
lets anyone share information but money
definitely doesn't work that way you
know in the u.s. we've credit cards and
we think of them as pretty global but
they're not in Kenya everyone uses a
mobile money system called m-pesa which
is on feature phones it's it's it's
really far advanced 43% of Kenyan GDP
flows through impreza and no one really
uses a credit card or in China everyone
uses Ali pay and the payment arm of of
Alibaba and so we've erected this kind
of Tower of Babel when it comes to money
on the Internet where we have a bunch of
different systems
none of which interoperate and our idea
with stripe is that by using stripe you
should just not be able to have a system
for processing
the cards but a way to accept money from
anyone anywhere and so you know neither
one of these answers is more correct
than the other they're just all
different answers at a variety of of
zoom levels and one phenomenon I think
is really interesting about startups is
they tend over time to to get higher and
higher up in in how they describe
themselves and that's okay and that
makes sense but the the sneaky thing
they do is they pretend that that's how
they viewed themselves all along and so
you've this great Silicon Valley
phenomenon of you know the founding myth
that you know we set out to
revolutionize at Discovery I mean what
do you mean and you know one of my
favorite examples of this is I saw an
interview with Elon Musk and I mean Elon
Musk is clearly an incredible
entrepreneur and I need someone I
respect to last but he was giving this
interview and the interviewer was asking
him you know payments electric cars
space travel you know what connects
these and young kind of looked very
thoughtful and he's like well when I was
in college I thought the the three
biggest opportunities for for mankind
were the Internet interplanetary space
travel and clean energy it's like really
that that very and and so what that
means is as you're trying to think you
know is this a valid startup idea you
know maybe you've identified a problem
but but it seems very tactical you don't
know what the what the broader vision is
one stark counter example here is I
really enjoyed Travis kalanick
in describing uber recently you know
ubers latest tagline is transportation
as reliable as running water available
to everyone but at Travis I remember in
a while ago described in an interview
and you know someone asked him why he
started uber and he said it was a
lifestyle thing me my co-founder and our
hundred friends could roll around San
Francisco like dollars in Mercedes us
classes and
so that's maybe a little before the you
know the transportation is as reliable
as running water and so I guess the
point I'm trying to make here is that
you don't always know in the early days
what the largest thing is for me and
Patrick when we when we start at the
stripe you know the the market research
we did was we knew this is something we
really wanted as developers and we we
had one or two friends who wanted us and
that seems like an addressable market
right there and and over time we've come
to realize that this is in fact a really
large and and meaty problem that we can
be tackling the other challenge and the
early days of startups well that sounds
kind of trite there's a lot of
challenges let's talk about another
challenge and one of my favorite media
tropes is the you know the the
multi-year overnight success people
talking about how quickly startups get
to scale I mean even in stripes okay so
you know I've seen a lot of newspaper
articles that literally described it as
an overnight success it's like hey you
weren't there in our case we spent a a
really long time in the early days
building out the product I'm trying to
figure out would it work and what the
right thing was and so to give you a
sense of scale here we started working
on stripe in the fall of 2009 and we
launched stripe in September 2011 which
was ran about two years later and I
remember you know right at the beginning
when we were starting it I I said to
Patrick you know yeah let's do it how
hard can it be and which gives you a
sense for our mindset and and then you
know the answer was two years of
difficulty we had not predicted that and
when we launched two years later does
anyone want to take a guess how many
users drive had
yeah close 50 so we'd spent two years
building out the the early product and
acquiring those those 50 users and you
know when you're spending two years
getting 50 users it doesn't feel like a
whole lot of progress like it feels like
things are going pretty slow and this is
the challenge you know if you have if
you're working on a start-up that's a
bad idea
it's gonna feel like slow going but also
if you're working on a start-up that's a
good idea it may feel like slow going -
I think the thing vas that really
allowed us to take off in these
subsequent years was the fact that since
we were spending so much time on each
one of those users since we were a hyper
focused on building out a great product
and since we weren't dealing with
problems of scale yes that allowed us to
really build a product that we wanted
one of the one of the cultures that said
in really early on was taking almost
abnormally good care of those early
users and so I think someone wrote a
blog post about this but we we set up
the the stripe API to email us anytime
someone ran into a bug so you know when
you run into a bug on on any site it
shows the error message or something in
that case on the stripe it would email
us and occasionally phone call us
because we figured you know when you're
there as a developer integrating this
product that you expect to be reliable
running into that bug is a terrible
experience and we wanted to fix it and
so it would alert us we would often I
mean we weren't doing anything else at
the time we were off and open our laptop
and start fixing us and send the user a
friendly email of you know hey that bug
you you discovered us there it's now
fixed and people's minds were blown by
this sometimes they even found it a bit
creepy we we set up a campfire room that
any of our customers could come into
really any hour of the day or night and
we even if if people were based in in in
the Bay Area we would let them come by
the office and we
just sit over their shoulder and help
them integrate stripe we had in the in
the bottom right of the stripe
dashboards a little prompts that would
change on every page load it would say
you know the thing you guys should
improve here or a feature I really want
is or the worst thing about that this
pages and people would fill it out and
hit enter and again because you know
there were so few users we would reply
it within 10 minutes and people find a
little odd
and what this meant was that even though
the user growth was you know happening
quite slowly in the early days it
actually had a really surprising viral
effect where people had a really good
experience they told their friends about
it and and we were able to spread
entirely through word-of-mouth even to
this day and we actually baked viral
mechanics into the product and so for
the longest time it was available in
invite-only beta mode and I you don't
really think of payment processing as a
really viral social thing and but the
only way for the longest time to get
access to stripe was was to get invited
by someone who knew us and so again you
had this phenomenon where people were
not only you know signing up for stripe
but being recommended to us by someone
who was already using us who knew how to
use us and it really helped not just
with user growth but user engagement the
other challenge you'll face as you go
through that early stage with with those
early customers is really figuring out
what is core to the product and what is
not you know maybe another way to phrase
this is what is what should be part of
your vision and what will need to change
as you hit obstacles with customers you
can even probably define vision as the
things that you're not willing to to
change there tends to be a lot of debate
over the the Lean Startup methodology
where you should you know have a product
showed some customers rapidly iterate
based on their
their feedback versus the very vision
driven product of you know I know what
this is and I know where it should go
and to me that's that's not really a
trade off at all in that you need some
small set of things at the vision that
you're not really willing to compromise
on and then with with the remainder I
mean if the market is telling you that
you're wrong you really need to listen
to that data you know in stripes case I
think you know we were really focused on
an instant onboarding experience
building a developer friendly - as our
path to Marcus and I think you know that
was stuff we were really willing to
compromise on if that wasn't a valid way
to build this company you know I'm not
sure we would have been able to pivot
out of that but in every other area we
we explored the Marcus we just kept
running into feedback from customers
that ended up being really critical to
allowing the product to succeed so it's
not a vision versus you know iteration
trade-off and it's a selection of the
things that you really believe in and
then being willing to to contort
yourself to make it work around that and
related to that in the vision category
is that there will be things in the
early days of a start-up that make sense
in the early days that that don't scale
later on and so you know it's not just a
question of you know it's more of a
continuum there are there aren't just
things that you should not change and
things that you should be willing to
change on a regular basis it's there
will be things that you should not
change for the first two years and then
gradually need to be unwound as you grow
and so you know in the early days of a
company it's probably really critical
that they focus on the US market you
know trying to win all markets is a
distraction but clearly over the long
term focusing solely on the US market is
wasteful and they should they should go
International or Facebook for the
longest time they had the mantra of move
fast and break things and this really
made sense for them they're trying to
have a really fast product kids but at a
certain size you get so big and so
interconnected that
moving fast and breaking things probably
is injure model and so they I mean they
recently explicitly acknowledged that
they were moving past this startups end
up having a really powerful path
dependence where you know it's not just
a question of arriving ash you know the
final answer and if you had if you had
found that final answer earlier you
could have gotten there much quicker
it's a question of you know building a
set of assumptions following those and
continually revisiting them you're not
just trying to arrive at the final form
for your product you're trying to get
all the intermediate forms in the
chemical reaction that gets you there
you know a good example of this is is
Microsoft they started out in the you
know in the hobbyist Markus building
basic compilers they could they couldn't
have stayed there and you know could
never have become the company they are
today as a result of you know building
compilers and they had to move upstream
and they're now basically an enterprise
company but at the same time they
couldn't have started as an enterprise
company because no one would have bought
from them these like two random college
kids and so again there's that this path
dependence to Microsoft's growth where
they had to become each one of their
stages to allow them to jump to the next
level may be another example of this is
you know going back to Eber if they had
just started out with their over X model
today doing ride-sharing they probably
would've been shut down pretty quickly
it required them to you know to succeed
they needed to start with the the limo
business get to such a scale that it was
a well known and well liked service and
then they could start doing ride-sharing
in some cities and prove that it was a
popular model the last thing I briefly
wanted to touch on on this topic is bad
of startup opportunities you know people
often ask this question of where do I
find the idea for a start-up and I think
in you know in stripes case it was you
know in hindsight it makes a lot of
sense
building an online business was really
really hard pre stripe I'm starting a
service to to make that easier would
seem to make a lot of sense and that
goes for for a lot of other companies as
well you know anyone who had ever taken
a cab in San Francisco you know should
have had the idea for uber or in the
case of slack you know stripe we
internally were struggling struggling
with the problem of team chats and not
only that everyone we knew is struggling
with the problem of team chat and and so
the idea to build a to build a company
to to tackle that it seems obvious in
hindsight but that obvious in hindsight
that obvious in hindsight doesn't really
help you right because you know if you
only realize these opportunities after
they've come along and someone has shown
you the path that doesn't really help
you get anywhere I'd know if any you
guys have read David Foster Wallace's
commencement speech called this's water
it's really really good and you should
you should check it out if you haven't
read us but you know energy uses the
story of a big fish passing to little
fish and the big fish test a little fish
hey guys how's the water and they swim
along and pass them and once it turns
the other and is like that was water and
he used this anecdote as you know to
then go on explain about being mindful
in the in the day-to-day lives that we
live and that there's sort of a little
bit like that in as you think about
opportunities on a day to day basis we
live in a world that's completely broken
in lots and lots of small or big ways
and we've come to just work around them
we've come to take them for granted and
so to spot opportunities requires you to
jump out of that mode briefly and
question how things work and be
unreasonable and suggesting that it's
not viable for them to work this way and
you know it should be interesting to
note that the
the companies that are often successful
in changing an industry are often not
started by insiders because the insiders
you know know too much about that
industry they've been swimming in that
water for for too long you know
certainly it was the case in in in
stripes case as we came to learn more
about how the payments industry worked
we could see the reasons why everything
worked the way it did you know before
stripe to get set up with payments
online you know generally took a few
weeks and it was a whole bunch of
paperwork and you know as you as you get
more into the banking industry and
people say you know oh well you know we
need to collect that information to run
our underwriting checks and fulfill our
kyc BSA requirements you're like mmm
yeah yeah and it requires you to stand
back and say you know wait a second this
is not how the internet works and so I
think there's a there's a certain
practice you get have to get into in how
you look at the world to stop accepting
everything is reasonable in how it works
we are all swimming an opportunity but
it's often really really hard to see it
and with that I think we might take a
break there and move to questions so
this the way it's gonna work I'm gonna
ask the first couple questions that I'm
gonna open up to you so you can be
noodling on the type of questions that
you want to ask John you mentioned
several times starting this with your
brother hmm is that a good idea to talk
about I mean obviously it's been very
successful but tell us about what it's
like and what the opportunities and the
challenges of starting a business with a
family member
yep so I get this question all the time
you know often from you know from
reporters or whatever and you know
generally my response is to say that
yeah we got all our disagreements out of
the way when we were five and then tried
to move the conversation along but now
that I've told you that so that won't
work here you know I think starting a
company with someone is I mean one just
on the face of it it's
you know it's often seven-hour or
seven-day weeks and 14-hour days again
again and again and going through a lot
of uncertainty a lot of setbacks but
also in the in the actual work you're
doing and the working style and you're
you're probably the the group of people
start in the company are learning a huge
amount as they go along you know they're
wrong a lot and discovering they're
wrong a lost and all this adds up to you
need to have a really good working
connection you know if you're already
another person you need to have a really
good working connection with them and if
you don't know the person you need to
develop that really fast and so I think
we were lucky in that you know Patrick
and I I mean not only had we grown up
together but we had worked in the
startup before we worked on projects
before and so all the the meta issues of
working style and how we work together
were out of the way and we could focus
squarely on the task at hand and I think
if you look at a lot of a lot of
successful teens you know generally they
had a history of working together you
know you often see people who worked
together for a long time at previous
jobs starting a company together I'm not
saying that's a necessary requirement
but I think if you actually look at the
data you have this phenomenon where it
requires you to either get lucky and
finding someone best you work really
well with or pick someone who are you
where you know that's the case did you a
very clear division of labor from the
beginning or is that something that's
evolved it was totally unclear in the
beginning in that you know there was
this huge amount of work and we both
just talked a little great and you chose
to go to Y Combinator mhm can you tell
us a little bit about that experience
and how it influenced the evolution of
the company yeah I think YC is really
valuable especially for people like us
where we were you know fairly new to the
valley and we were you know working in a
business that required us to understand
how how the valley operated and work
you know we it would have been very
useful to have a network for hiring for
a business development for you know
raising money things like this and we
didn't um and you know most investors
will say you know on their home page
that they don't accept cool pictures you
know you have to be in that Network
already to be able to participate in
this system and so YC is quite cool and
unusual in the way that you know there's
a standard application forum on the on
the site and that's actually the only
way that they accept pitches is you you
know anyone from anywhere in the world
can can fill that out and get a spot and
so well I think what was valuable for us
was the fact that you know we were we
were pretty new to this it helped us you
know get into this world and you know to
give you a concrete example in the early
days of stripe it was I mean it was a
lot of work convincing people to to use
it it was this new unproven tool that
you were going to build your whole
business on I mean it's kind of scary
undertaking and so it was a lot of our
early customers were were YC companies
who we knew through that you know they
knew we were we weren't going to
disappear in the morning and they were
willing to to integrate Streb fabulous
so anyone in the room want to start out
with the first question
okay childhood childhood yes was the
question asking about his childhood as
an entrepreneur yeah
grew up in the middle of nowhere in
Ireland in a small town in County
Tipperary and you know read a lot of
books use the internal art I mean
childhoods pre-internet and post
Internet Jews do seem to be very
different in that pre-internet you're
mostly limited to a very local circle
and
no post-internet you're making friends
with people all over the world and
learning a new thing you know I first
coded when I was 14 and I built a
website that Patrick subsequently had to
me rather subsequently comprehensively
hacked and which I guess a good lesson
and never try anything I'm not so bitter
about that one but yeah you know III
think you know 20 years ago would it
have been as easy for you know me to
come out here from to come out here from
there and do something like stripe it it
seems unlikely yeah so clearly you're
someone who has a lot of ideas right
starting at a very young age you are
building things how did you pick this as
the thing that you said I know I'm gonna
put all my energy behind this problem to
solve because this is a huge problem for
a lot of us right it can be an
interesting dinner table conversation or
hanging out with a friend saying you
know this is a problem someone should
solve this which is the one you say this
is one I'm gonna solve yeah I think
that's a really hard problem and you
know it sort of comes back to the you
know bad ideas take a long time and you
know never quite achieve escape velocity
but good ideas often take a take a
really long time to achieve escape
velocity too you know in the case of
stripe it was actually for the the first
few months we were also working on this
series of iPhone apps you know it was
one of the projects we were working on
but we're also in college at the time so
we're juggling kind of class in these
iPhone apps and stripe and so it was
definitely not our exclusive focus I
think the thing that really convinced us
in the early days was and this might be
specific to you know more developer
business focused companies rather than
consumer which can get the skill really
quickly but I think in the in our case
was really convinced us was the fact
that the users we had were so so
passionate you know this was not just
for them you know something marginally
better
but they thought that it was it was a
life-changing the revolutionary and they
wanted to tell all their friends you
know they wanted us to build a way for
them to invite their friends to it you
know that seemed to really get back got
our attention and so I guess you know
most of the metrics that people talk
about day to day like revenue or user
numbers those are all lagging metrics
and you as the person actually working
in the product you have access to
leading metrics and so you know
apparently with with snapchat when the
earliest errors are wound the most
compelling metrics in the early days was
the the number of times per day each
person used it in that you know even if
this wasn't really big yet it was
growing very quickly and it seemed to
have a really deep connection with each
of its its users
and somebody for us I think the the the
passion that the early users had about
the product was that leading metric that
indicated to us that something was there
so but I you know I think in in each
case that leading metric is going to be
different but you want to find what that
leading metric is to be able to judge
whether this is going to take off or not
so this is a space that has become very
very busy with lots of other companies
how do you think about your competition
is this something that you think of it
as a cat and mouse game with features do
you say I don't pay attention to them
we've got our own path talk a little bit
about competitors yeah it's it's sort of
funny in the you know in the early days
when we started stripe you know people
would say to us like really payments
like well we just turned to payments
company and then in 2012 they were like
all these payments companies and people
would say to us you know man payments
that's like a super hot space that was a
great idea you guys starting that you're
just like the whole time you're kind of
nonplussed by all D's by all these
reactions I think there's there's it's
it's important to be really clear in
your own mind and as time goes on be
good at communicating what is unique
about what you're doing and so you know
in the early days people would always
ask us they're like so payments unlike
with the design focus and it starts with
s so it's like sorta like square right
and actually when you think about it
there are two entirely different
businesses in that stripe is is a
technology product you know using it
more or less always involves codes we're
interested in what you can build using
this this toolkit we've developed for
you and a really leveraged way online
where Square is you know entirely
offline almost entirely aimed at the the
small business segment and offer
face-to-face transactions and you know I
think similarly with with lots of
competitors people who only have a
surface level understanding of your
business will you know will tend to want
to lump you into some category and it's
it's very important that you be able to
get across what it is that's not just
happens to be different today in the
feature set but what's different about
where you're going and you know in the
asymptotes of these two companies where
they end up and I think that's you know
that's not only important to be able to
explain it but it's important in an
existential sense and that you know
hopefully you are doing something
different so speaking of doing something
different I understand you now deal in
Bitcoin as well that's obviously
something that's very interesting and a
little bit controversial maybe you can
talk about what you see is the future of
alternative currencies like Bitcoin yep
so you know I mentioned earlier the
Tower of Babel effect where online we
have all these different payment systems
that are completely non interoperable
and so you know we in the West happily
use our credit cards you know people in
Africa use a variety of mobile money
systems same in in various parts of Asia
you know people in China use the rally
pay accounts you have this perfectly
connected online world and then this
perfectly vulcanized you know economic
landscape and it's it's really harmful
because it means then you know the the
products we use are artificially limited
by you know you have the u.s.
international Chinese internet as a
result and so I think Bitcoin is
what is most exciting for me about
Bitcoin is that global aspect it's the
fact that everyone's bitcoins are the
same everyone's bitcoins work together
with each other
and that no one has to you know come
along and enable a Bitcoin for a certain
currency you know there's there's no
committee that decides that bitcoin is
going to South Africa in 2018 it's just
there that's how it works
and so you know we recently added
Bitcoin to stripe and it's it's one of
the instruments you can accept and from
a product point of view one of the
things that we have always taught is
really important is moving beyond this
you know I render a credit card form on
my site that works for a very small set
of people to being that universal
connector for people that you just say I
want to accept money and stripe lets you
accept money from anyone no matter what
they're doing be a Bitcoin or whatever
the other thing I'll say about Bitcoin
is I think you know with that original
Bitcoin paper that is you know
phenomenally prescient in retrospect
like a you know that's it it is a truly
great standalone paper that you know
appeared out of nowhere and still people
aren't quite sure who even wrote it and
and what that's done is you know one
it's kicked off a Bitcoin movement but
two it's kicked off a whole
cryptocurrency movement that it's got
people thinking about this space and in
a way they weren't before and so you
know people are arguing about you know
what what is the the perfect consensus
algorithm and you know what are the
right constants in the you know in the
in the hashing functions if you're going
to use hashing or proof work or whatever
and you know you give people arguing
about every detail and you know you have
some people the moaning the the
fracturing that's happening where you
have all these altcoins like litecoin
and zero coin and things like this but
but to me that's really exciting and
that people are not only saying you know
this is a really cool technology but
this is a really cool technology space
and we should explore all the
possibilities that are in it and stripe
funded a nonprofit called stellar and
which is developing a cryptocurrency and
it's it's very interesting it lets you
trade not just you know with Bitcoin the
currency is Bitcoin whereas with
Celer you can actually trade dollars or
euros or pounds you know things
denomination in the actual currency and
it doesn't have it doesn't use hashing
and fur for consensus or proof of work
is users kind of a more see a like model
and so I think cryptocurrencies are
totally in line with this general
mission we believe in which is you know
the the Internet economy should not be
the u.s. it should be the world and we
need to fight really hard to make that
happen
yes ability to find out what's the right
thing to do in terms of culture and
hiring when no one's really told me
about it so I'm gonna repeat the
question I'm gonna see if I've got it is
that
listen there's all this how to start a
company information out there you didn't
have access to it you know what's the
difference between those people who read
all the books watch all the videos are
listening right now and and the people
like you who did it by the city your
pants well you know I think it's it's
maybe giving us a you know a little bit
too much credit to to say that we
succeeded you know in entirely of our
own accord and you know had had no and
helping us you know there's the the old
quip about about libertarians being
mostly rich people and you know
believing in the in the power of the
free market to get them to where they
are but um but you know I think in our
case we were we were very lucky to have
a lot of advice from people who had done
it before you know it'd be a people via
the YC Network and Peter Thiel was a
very early investor in stripe you know
that was
but that was a fun one he's actually our
first significant investor and you know
going into the office of Peter Thiel and
saying you know online payments are
totally broken who caused this mess but
he knows an awful lot about building
companies you know not just through
PayPal but being the the first outside
investor in facebook and you know a
co-founder of pound here right at these
other successful companies same with
Sequoia things like this or you know
studying wasps various companies had -
you know emerged in the 70s 80s 90s did
and you know trying to draw the
conclusions of what made them successful
like I said you know if you if any of
you guys wants to end my fun startup
history Reading Club you're you're
welcome to but yeah I don't think we
were we were on our own at alders
there's always been a pretty good source
of advice and you know going back to the
the point of whitewashing and you know
the corporate history is always tending
to be a bit more of an official history
you know for me the best advice has
always been someone who is there
firsthand who in a one-on-one context is
willing to tell you not only the the
official sanitized version but and
here's the time we nearly lost
everyone's data which actually happened
for a major consumer Internet company
great yes so the question is what
worries you the most right now and what
challenges are you trying to overcome
probably two things and you know I think
the the things we worry about them the
challenges are sort of the same so I'll
answer them together I think one is this
product product strategy product
prioritization product planning whatever
you want to call us and is always going
to be really hard and I think you know
people think it's it's going to be hard
if things aren't going well but it's
even harder things are
well because you're trying to you know
model the future and see the knock-on
effects of of doing things with huge
amounts of uncertainty and so you know
in our case we have a very successful
you know with a very successful
subscription product that we really
believe in and we're expanding and you
know we're also expanding
internationally and there's only a
finite amount that we can work on and so
you know you're you're at a certain
point faced with a choice you know
should we be investing in subscriptions
or expanding internationally and you
know the answer is both and you have to
always be making these calls and
constantly revisiting your calls when it
comes to what you should be working on
and it's it's so so hard to predict
upfront what actually ends up being
being kind of a major part of your of
your business
so I just want to build on this how
often do you revisit your strategy
because you know you can't do it every
day it's sort of like you know you're
digging up the seed every day to see if
it's precedent right okay but you also
can't do it till it's an oak and you go
oh my gosh I really wanted to cherry yes
I think the the strategy you revisit all
the time I think what companies have to
get good at is being willing to let
things take the time to being willing to
give them a chance to actually go
somewhere or nos because you know
especially as the company grows you have
all this pressure not just externally
but the pressure you all set on
yourselves internally and you know one
of the tougher things is saying you know
look I know that the needle hasn't moved
in in you know on this yet but we you
know we said initially that you know we
believe this is going to be really
important going forward and we we still
believe that and it's just gonna it's
just gonna take time you know I think
say bitcoin is a perfect example you
know I think if you look if you go ask
any one who's accepting Bitcoin is as a
significant fraction of their of their
transaction volume the answer will be no
because the the consumer demand isn't
there yet and so you're in this chicken
and egg situation
and so is it irrational for these people
to have Bitcoin on their sites I mean no
it's just that they want to give it at
that time and so they're probably
constantly revisiting their strategy of
you know should we be investing in
Bitcoin but what the the secret sauce is
in the patience to know when you when
you should be giving things time and
that's that's an arse that's like
risotto you can be patient when it's
your company and there aren't investors
but you now have a lot of investors who
probably have a strong opinion so you've
got a board and you meet with them can
you tell us a little bit about your
relationship with your board and how
maybe how you manage the board how the
man board manages you
you gotta find patient investors and I I
think the good investors get that this
is how this works and and they you know
the good investors have also seen it
some amount before and so you know in
facebook you know in Facebook's case
does anyone remember that Facebook in
the very early days used to have banner
ads they're just gonna sell ad space on
Facebook that you could buy the banner
at the top of the page but you know it
took them a few variations before they
found a really good revenue model that
that's that's now doing well and so I
think again you know in that that
collective amnesia that we that we all
have where the you know we only really
remember that the successful stuff and
it's it's easy to view it as you know
why can't you just be like Facebook and
you know quickly arrive at the correct
answer and it's important that the
investors you find be able to understand
that part of the of the creative process
great yes like the personal transition
you've had going from you know what you
were just an engineer working in the
early days to now be CEO thank you enjoy
being CEO I don't you know you're the
CEO boy co-founder I do do you enjoy
that role warned you miss coding yet
still code sometimes I'm not the CEO I'm
the president but I'll take the
suggestion to the board
and I I agree for what it's worth and
now I'm kidding
I mean you definitely do operate in a
different way
ash every at every stage of the company
you know in the early days when it's
just two of you we actually spent the
weight we spent the very early days in
the stripe the first few weeks working
on it from Buenos Aires it was a January
break-in in college and we you know we
didn't want to work in the u.s. because
we didn't have you know with student
visas and not work visas we didn't want
to go home to our links to be super
distracting or whatever and so we did
the logical thing and went to Buenos
Aires and it was awesome that is like a
city that works in a hacker schedule
everything is open till 5:00 a.m. and
has Wi-Fi is great that's a slightly
different experience to you know a 200
person company now and I think what you
you need to not guess you know you hear
these stories of people who kind of want
to stay coding to the detriment of other
things you know at a certain point you
you have to acknowledge that you know
the productive thing for me is not going
to be you know directly doing this
myself or directly coding but you know
working on working on something
different and you have to get out ahead
of that I think the other thing that you
have to get good at is pretty quickly
learning new skills because we're going
to be doing things like recruiting or
you know running a board meeting or
running a staff meeting or running an
all-hands or all this kind of stuff that
you probably haven't done before and I
think it takes a it requires you to be
willing to be not good at things in
front of a large group of people and be
pretty open to feedback to actually get
good at those things so on that note
when you look back right imagine you're
starting all over again it's a few years
ago because it's really only a few years
are there any very specific things that
you go wow I wish I had really done
something differently that would have
been really meaningful I mean help help
us understand so that everyone here can
learn from that yeah
I think the reassuring thing and one you
know wouldn't pattern in a lot of the
you know if you read these histories of
companies is just how much stuff they
screwed up and you know that should be a
really heartening less and it's you know
you can still scrub that much stuff and
get away with it um you know there is
this you know they talk about in the
early days of Google how you know they
had this one machine I think it was the
script that Sergey Rose doing all the
indexing of the entire web and a certain
point they just like couldn't keep up
with the growth of the web and you know
everything was slowing down search
results took you know multiple seconds
to actually respond and this is when
Google was getting reasonably large and
you know they they fixed it and it's now
you know now hyper focused on speed but
it really was quite broken there along
the way and you know the same with you
know Facebook who stumbled to lots of
different revenue models before arriving
at the one they wanted things like this
and so it's the reassuring thing is you
can screw up a lot of stuff I think you
did right luckily and we got everything
right and I think the two things you
really can't screw up our product
direction where I mean if you if you go
down the wrong road that's that's really
hard to pull back from and the other
thing is is hiring just because you know
a bad mistake when it comes to hiring is
so demotivating it can you know it can
spread so badly to the rest of the
company that you really have to get a
lot of hard is right I think the other
thing is as you grow you know the
correct way to do hiring is not I am
filling someone to you know to do this
role and and and you know fill this this
this slot it's the correct way to view
hiring is is branches of a tree that
when you hire this person you're not
only bringing them but you're bringing
their effect on the culture and all the
other people they're going to bring in
with them and you know the the the the
norms and the working style they have
that'll spread throughout the company
and and as time goes on you know the
those hires have you know you have less
and less influence on the company and
all the new people you're bringing in
have more and so you know hiring you you
can't really screw up great yes you talk
a little bit about how they're gonna
scale that kind of hiring you're doing
now so you and Patricks so interview
everyone sometimes you know if people go
through projects before you decide to
work with them how do you do that as the
company goes from 200 to so the question
is how do you scale the hiring process
to know you've got the right person as
you get so big that's very relevant
question it's it's a discussion we're
having internally right now I think a
lot of it is as you you know go from and
you know speaking of these questions of
scaling let's be clear you know stripe
there's 200 people right now we're in
the process of of growing a last you
know we'll probably grow you know we'll
add a significant number of people this
year but you know if we've messed it all
up you won't see the results until a few
years down the road and so to take all
my advice on scaling with a pinch of
salt and but with with with scaling in
particular I think it's moving from
things being at a gut level you know
this doesn't feel right I'm not so sure
about this to making things very
explicit and so you know in the early
days I think companies spend a lot of
time talking about culture fit and you
know hopefully the various people at the
company know what that means and no pot
set of traits that they believe are
important in hires but you know as the
company grows you have to make pass
explicit and you have to say you know
the this is the set of things we believe
makes someone succeed at stripe this is
the set of traits we believe are
important this is the set of skills we
think someone needs to come in in that
role and and that feels kind of weirdly
artificial in the in the early days and
it's it's inefficient in the early days
because you know if you're being so
explicit about everything in a
fast-moving environment you'll get
weighed down but
as the you know as the company grows it
will end up in this complete game of
telephone unless you are really explicit
about you know it's something like
hiring what is important in a hire so
clearly every single person contributes
to the culture mmm and that's but that's
one of the variables that affects
culture do you think about the culture
of the company you and and what other
things do levers do you pull to
influence the culture at the
organization yeah so everyone does and I
think you know some people pitch that as
a you know as a thing to be kept in
check or you know restrained or whatever
and you know people often ask the
question like you know how do you keep
the culture from changing and I guess to
me that question Celeste suggests a huge
amount of hubris in that you know to
suggest that that initial kernel of
culture that you had is you know the
perfect culture that any company could
have and does not deserve any improving
and yet something seems off there and so
the correct question is not how do you
keep the culture from changing its what
culture do you want to have and how do
you get there and sometimes you'll
believe that you have that culture
already and you want you know you want
you want to teach new hires that but but
I think often times it'll if you're
being really thoughtful about it it's
about recognizing a deficiency in your
culture and how do we inculcate that and
I think I can identify various points
throughout the history of stripe where
the culture actually improved from you
know someone coming in and them bringing
in some new culture with them you know
as an example of this I think in the
early days startup to tend to be very
fly-by-night shoot from the hip
not at all metrics driven and maybe
that's necessary that maybe you need to
have a you know a clear idea of where
you're going and ignore the data to some
to some degree but it's really important
as they grow to become more metrics
oriented and actually look at usage look
at how people are using the product and
bake that into future product
development and you know Weaver
definitely started off not very metrics
driven and we have become
more metrics driven over time and I
think that that was a good example of
you know a concrete place I cannot
identify the culture as as having
improved there are other factors that
always come into play like the physical
space different rewards incentives do
you think about that as part of the
culture as well it is though it's a bit
more you know I think the hopefully the
physical space is you know a
manifestation of something different or
a manifestation of something larger
rather than rather than you know the
culture itself and that you know if your
culture is you know we have foosball
it's a bit like cool okay great um but
but you know if your culture is you know
at stripe for example we you know we
serve meals at the company and rather
than having kind of cafe style seating
with the round tables we have long
dining room tables kind of Hogwarts
style and we think that's really
valuable because it means that you know
in a fast growing team people get the
chance to meet each other that they
don't but they might and otherwise and
you know we very much don't want stripe
to become these silos for you know you
have the finance people and the
marketing people in the engineers and
they're all and they're kind of creeks
you know what we wants to be the case
that people at stripe have a lot of
empathy for how different parts of the
company work and are pretty well rounded
and so you know that that's an example I
would point out as you know where the
space is is hopefully an indication of
some larger cultural thing rather than
you know if is about it okay that's
exactly what I mean great thank you yeah
please stand up and speak really can you
repeat it yeah what would be your advice
for working or not with a person or a
team what would be your advice for
working or not working with a person or
a table you mean as a as a co-founder or
when it comes to hiring
well I I guess the two things to think
about are one I think the quality and
tenor of your personal interactions
actually matters a lot you know there
are some things that are absolutely
table stakes like honesty and integrity
and if you see any bad signs there you
should run away at 100 miles an hour and
but then there's you know there's deeper
things about your your interaction and
your working style and you know I think
one interesting question that you should
really think about is how much should
you argue with you know someone you're
working closely with because it's not
obvious that you want to be in you know
you clearly just don't want to be the to
the same people that's kind of wasteful
you you you know you hopefully have some
have some conflict in some diversity of
opinion such that you're both bringing
different perspectives to the table but
at the same time you probably don't want
to be too far you know too diverse in
opinions where you know Max Levchin
describes how when they merged XCOM and
PayPal you know PayPal were all UNIX
people and Windows or and XCOM were all
Windows Server people and they kind of
smushed them together and it was bedlam
because you had these two people who had
you know Red Team Blue Team two
completely different ways of doing
things and you know it's unclear whether
one was you know better than the other
in that context but they certainly
didn't work together and so if you know
if it's productive disagreement that
that let you know that results in a
better product that's great if it's kind
of stylistic disagreement that you can't
get past and you do just have two
different approaches for doing something
then that's maybe a sign that you're not
going to be able to work that well
together I'm sure that you would agree
this was absolutely fascinating please
join me and thanking John Collison
you